[音楽]
私はいじめ問題を扱う弁護士ですこれまでたくさんの学校でいじめに関する授業をし
たくさんの先生方から相談を受けてきました
実は私は法学部出身の弁護士ではありません
教育学部出身です教諭免許も持っています
ですから教育問題にとても関心がありご縁があっていじめに関わるようになりました
ではそもそもなぜ私が弁護士を目指したのかというところなんですけれども
あえて一言でいうならばそれはテレビドラマの影響です
昔天海祐希さんが弁護士役を演じるドラマがありました
その弁護士がとてもかっこよく輝いて見えて私もあんな風になりたいと憧れたわけです
ドラマの中での甘くさんはいつも正しいとても正しいことを言います
ですから私も彼女のようにまっすぐと正しいことがいえる弁護士になりたいと思ってい
ましたし今でもそう思っています
しかしながら私が扱ういじめ問題では正しいことを言っても相手の心に届かないことが
あります
今日はその一部を少しだけご紹介したいと思います
弁護士になってへいじめ問題に取り組みはじめた頃私はいじめの語られ方にある特徴が
あることに気づきました
それはとてもドラマティックにとても
センセーショナルに感情的に
語られるということですテレビなどを通して大人が子どもに語るのはこんなひどい
いじめがあったよ
こんな悲しい結果酷い結果が生じたよと言うのです
そして最後に大事な命が失われるからいじめは絶対やってはいけないというのです
これは私にとってあまりに当たり前のことであったんだ目
気付いたということ自体に自分でも少し驚きました
そしてこれに気付いた事で自分がなかなか難しい道を進んでいくことになるということ
に最初は全然気づいていませんでした
冒頭でも申し上げた通り私は教育学部出身の弁護士なので
せっかくいじめに関わるのであれば中高生向けにいじめに関する授業を作ろうと思い
ました
そしていじめに対する考え方を養えるように一つの事例に対して皆で議論できるような
授業を作りました
事例の内容はこんな感じです
ある子が同じグループの別の小から dvd を借ります
しかしその子はその dvd をなかなか返さない上にやっと買えしたかと思ったら
それに傷をつけて返してしまう
それがきっかけでその後はグループのみんなから仲間外れにされてしまう
そして学校に行きたくなくなってしまうというものです
皆さんはこれを聞いて最初にまず何を思いましたか
いくつかの学校でやってみて私は少しだけ驚きました
思っていたよりもこんなものはいじめじゃないという意見がずっと多かったからです
悪いことをした人は仲間外れにされて当然だ
クラス全員から無視されたわけでもない
一部のし生徒たちからハブられたぐらいでいじめというのはおかしい
どの意見もとても強いものでした
また私の事例はテレビでねぇ年地形のテレビですとか大丈夫ですとかそういったもので
も紹介されているため
大人からもたくさんのご意見をいただきました
やはりいじめではないという意見はそれなりにあって
自分はもっとひどいいじめを受けていたこんなものまでいじめと言ったら子供が弱く
なる
なんでもかんでもいじめと言ったらコミュニケーションできなくなるなどという意見も
ありました
つまりこの程度のものであればよくあること
些細なこといじめというには大げさすぎるというわけです
なぜ大げさだと思うのでしょうか
それはおそらくいじめと言ったらテレビで見るようなひどいもの命に関わりそうなもの
をあるいは何の落ち度もない可哀想な被害者をイメージするからだと思います
私たちは口々にいじめを止めをやめようと言っていますがそこで止めようとされている
いじめはもしかするとテレビで見るようなひどいものや被害者側に何の落ちるともない
ものだけかもしれないということです
分かりやすさのために餌を用意しました
縦軸が行為の程度これは主に集団が行う行為です
横軸が相手の苦痛の程度です
いじめは集団水にもあってどんどんエスカレートしていくのが特徴です
他方で相手の普通の程度もそれに伴ってどんどん増していきますそしてその
も普通にどれくらい耐えられるかというのは個人差があるうえに
外からは分かりません5限界が来てしまうか分からないわけです
ですからエスカレートしたひどいものだけをいじめとしてそれを止めをやめようと言っ
ていても本当のいじめ対策にはなりません
むしろておくれに
なってしまう場合のほうが多いわけです
しかしながら私たちがイメージするいじめというのは主にこの部分
見解直前のこの部分です
ですから大事な命が失われるからいじめはやめようという語られ方になるのです
では残りのこの部分は
何なんでしょう
ここは止めなくていいんでしょ
もし辞めた方がいいのであればそれはなぜなんでしょ
私はこの部分にこそいじめ問題の本質を考えるヒントがあると思っています
ですから先ほどのような事例を使って生徒さんたちと一緒にこの問題を考えているわけ
です
ちなみに法律は相手の苦痛がスタートする
この部分から全体をいじめと考えています
いじめを小さいうちに発見して重大化を防止するためです
ですから私が先ほど取り上げた地でのようなものもいじめ
法律上のいじめということになります
さて
こういったものまでもいじめということになると生徒さんたちの次に困惑するのが現場
の牽制方です
先生方からすればいじめる方もいじめられる方も大事な生徒です
可愛い生徒たちにいじめっ子やいじめられっ子のレッテルを貼りたくありませんです
から
被害者や加害さといった力関係のようなものが生じてしまう
いじめではなくトラブルとしてこの問題を対応したいと考えるようです
私はこれまでたくさんの生徒さんとたちと関わってきましたし
先生方とも一緒にお仕事をしてきましたですからこの気持ちはとてもよくわかります
しかしながら私はこの解決方法には反対です
なぜならばこういうことが起きるからです
私は
この問題に初めて直面したのは授業後のアンケートでした
そこにはこう書いてありました
担任の先生がこの事例はいじめる方もいじめられる方もどちらも悪いと言っていました
わたしもそう思います私は人からこれ借りた物を大切にしようと思います
この一見どこも問題のなさそうなこの感想
これがいわゆるいじめられるほうも悪いという理屈です
これは危険とても危険な対応ですなぜならばいじめをエスカレートさせる可能性がある
からです
集団を一定程度正当化してしまう
そういった側面がありますですからこれはとても危険な対応です
当然ですが相手に落ち度があるからといっていじめていいことにはなりません
いじめというのは手段の選択です何か
腹が立ったりいらだったりそうしたときにそれを解決する手段はたくさんあります
相手と話し合ったり少し時間を置いたり
仲裁してくれる誰かを連れてきたいそうしたすべての手段を放棄してあえて相手に苦痛
を与えるという手段を選択しているわけです
その手段は間違ってるんだよやっちゃいけないんだよダメなんだよということを大人は
子どもにきちんと教えてあげる必要があると思いますそこを曖昧にしてはいけないの
です
ではなぜダメなのかなぜやってはいけないのかそれは人の尊厳を傷つけるからです
尊厳というのはその人がまわりの人とか家族とか
そうした人たちから愛されてきたりあるいは自分自身が迷ったり苦しんだりしながらも
一つ一つ積み上げてきた
その人がその人であるための角のようなものです
いじめはそれを否定し機
図付壊しますだからやってはいけないのです
確かに仲間外れや虫から会などは外から見ればたいしたことではない
些細なことよくあることなのかもしれません
しかしながら私たち大人は知っていますそれが自分に向けられたときにいかに深く
傷つくかどれほど自分が自分であることの自信を失うか
そしてその失った自信が容易には回復しないということも知っています
また逆に相手の尊厳を傷つけることがいかに重大でどれほど後に後悔するかということ
も知っているはずです
大人が子供にいじめを語るとき自分の被害経験を語る人がいても加害経験を語る人は
ほとんどいません
理屈の上では被害者の数よりも加害者の数の方が多いはずであるにもかかわらずです
それだけ後に後悔しそっと心の内にしまっている大人が多いということです
ですから私たち大人は子どもたちに対し
人の尊厳が傷つけられるからいじめはやってはいけない
それは相手の命が失われるとか節なはれないとかそういうことは関係ないということを
正面から論じる必要があると思いますそこに向き合う必要があると思います
それは私がこれまで歩んできたようにとても難しいことなのかもしれません
たくさんの大人地区大人たちや子供たちからでもとかだってとかそんなの綺麗事だとか
それは偽善者だとかそういった事を言われるかも知れませんまたあるいは被害者に対し
そんな風だから仲間外れにされてしまうんだよそれも社会勉強のうちだよなどと思って
しまい自分自身が試されることもあるかもしれません
それでも私たち大人たちが試行錯誤を繰り返しながらこの問題に向き合い続けていく
ことが大切なのではないかと思うのです
それが一人ひとりが自分らしく生きられる社会
個人が尊重される社会につながっていくのではないかと思うのです
借り物に傷をつけるような失敗をしたかもしれない
一人だけチームの和を乱したかもしれない
空気が読めないかもしれない誰かを傷つけてしまったかもしれない
一人だけみんなと違うかもしれないそうしたきっかけで仲間外れや虫から回押されて
苦しんでいる人たちがいます
1本しかしたら自分が悪いのかもしれないとじっと耐えている人たちがいます
私はそうした人たちにそれはいじめなんだよ
いけないことなんだよ声を上げていいんだよ辛いと言っていいんだよと言ってあげ
られる大人でありたいと思っていますそのためにこれからもこの問題と向き合っていき
たいと思っていま
ますこれが私がたくさんの人たちに助けられながら一つ一つ積み上げてきた
私が私であるための核ですご清聴ありがとうございました
ん
[音楽]